on a beaucoup parlé ces derniers jours
une application numérique sur un stade
un smartphone qui permettrait de tracer
les personnes et les notifier d'une dans
le cas où ils auraient été mises en
contact avec une personne contaminée par
le par le virus
donc c'est véritablement dans le cadre
d'un déconfinement que cette application
pourrait voir le jour
on y travaille le gouvernement y
travaillent elle a déjà d'ailleurs un ex
top cow vide et le gouvernement se veut
rassurant il nous dit c'est sera basé
sur le rat strict volontariat
donc pas de d'applications imposé en
tout cas c'est ce que nous dit le
gouvernement aujourd'hui il n'y aurait
pas non plus de géolocalisation c'est à
dire que les données de mobilité des
personnes ne serez pas tout tracé
traqué traités par le gouvernement et
pour cela ils utiliseraient une
technologie bluetooth donc une
technologie qui permet à une faible
distance de registre et un contact une
mise en relation avec un autre téléphone
donc voilà ce qu'on nous dit volontariat
pas de géolocalisation est une
application qui permettrait d'être
notifiés si nous avons été mises en
contact avec une personne mise en
contact à dire que si on a été proche
d'une personne alors la proximité tout
ça ce sont des paramètres qu'il faudra
que les scientifiques devront déterminer
quelle distance combien de temps mais en
tout cas voilà une fois que ces
paramètres ont été posées on pourrait
avoir une notification que nous direz à
1 pendant les six derniers jours
quatorze derniers jours vous avez été
mises en contact
vous avez été en contact et à proximité
d'une personne qui a contaminé
voilà ce qu aujourd'hui nous dit le
gouvernement et là évidemment il ya
plein de questions qui se pose parce que
on met
un focus sur une application qui
s'inspire d'ailleurs d'une application
un singapourienne triste ou gadins et
met tout ça doit s'insérer dans un cadre
c'est pas c'est pas une application
miracle c'est pas une baguette magique
que c'est pas ça qui fera que la
population sera mieux protégée parce
qu'on va mettre cette application
donc on attend beaucoup ou
d'explications et le gouvernement ont
d'ailleurs est assez sincère qu'est ce
qui nous dit que tout ça ils attendront
pour faire davantage de communiquer là
dessus mais tous savent aussi présuppose
en amont pour que cette application est
un sens cela présuppose qu'il y ait un
dépistage de la population un dépistage
massif et systématique en amour et puis
en aval il faut qu'on puisse nous dire
qu'est ce que qu'est ce qu'on va faire
de cette notification
une fois qu'on est notifiée et ce que
bon on voit très bien ok est ce que est
ce qu'on doit aller se faire tester
est-ce qu'on doit se mettre en
quarantaine si on est testé positif tout
ça ce sont des questions ouvertes et il
faudra que le gouvernement puisse nous
véritablement communiquer de manière
très transparente pour nous dire les
applications puisque cela va poser dans
le cadre de l'application elle-même en
amont et en aval
ça me posais plein de questions de
droits et de libertés fondamentales